[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
alain colin lebedev bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions à distance vous
êtes enseignante chercheur spécialiste
des sociétés post soviétique professeur
à l'université de paris-x nanterre on
voulait voir avec vous ce matin ce qu'il
se passe c'est ce qu'il se dit côté
russe de la frontière donc après six
jours d'invasion en ukraine en partie
parce qu'on a du mal à saisir vu d'ici
l'écho que cette guerre a en russie
comment la raconte-t-elle cette guerre
alors je pense que le premier élément
qu'il est important de savoir c'est que
la majorité des russes ne reçoit pas du
tout les mêmes informations que nous sur
le conflit armé ceux qui s'informent via
la télévision et les médias
d'état ou approuvés par l'état en fait
on entend que jamais le mot guerre on
parle du nord intervention armée parle
d'une intervention armée plutôt limité à
un territoire voilà c'est un petit peu
flou on mentionne les ville de kharkiv
on mentionne la ville de kiev mais en
même temps on parle de la protection des
populations russophones du donbass de la
région à l'est à l'est de l'ukraine on
ne mentionne pas les pertes humaines
côté russe
tout seulement hier en fait le ministère
de la défense a admis que oui il y avait
quelques victimes côté russe mais
absolument sans donner de chiffres et
donc voilà on a une grande partie des
russes qui sont maintenus dans une pour
l'instant dans une bulle informationnel
où ils ne savent pas véritablement ce
qui se déroule sur le territoire
ukrainien alors bien évidemment il y à
des russes qui savent parce qu'internet
reste accessible et quand on cherche
l'information on la trouve facilement
quand on veut remettre en cause ce
discours de l'état en fait il y a
beaucoup de médias d'opposition de
réseaux sociaux etc qui communique sur
ses excuses sur ce qui se passe et donc
on voit apparaître des mouvements de
protestation dans différents cercles
delà de la société russe mais je dirais
que voilà c'est une on a vraiment de
russie aujourd'hui la russie qui est
consciente de la situation
et la russie qui pour l'instant ignore
véritablement ce qui se passe sachant ça
comment peut-on mesurer analyser le
soutien dont ont bénéficié vladimir
poutine dans l'opinion publique où
précisément l'ampleur de la contestation
en russie
alors c'est bien évidemment très
compliqué en ce moment on a une seule et
première enquête d'opinion publique qui
vient de tomber qui vient d'un institut
de sondage pas très fiable parce que
contrôlée par l'état mais ont néanmoins
ces chiffres sont à prendre avec une
certaine attention où ils vont dire 68 %
des russes soutiennent l'intervention
l'intervention armée en en ukraine alors
mis à part toutes les réserves que je
viens de dire sur le fait qu'en fait les
russes ne savent pas exactement ce
qu'ils sont en train de soutenir il y a
une chose une lecture que le pouvoir
russe a réussi à imposer toutes ces
dernières années c'est l'idée que la
responsabilité de l'escaladé et du côté
des occidentaux et notamment du côté de
l'otan que la russie en fait et plutôt
une victime dans cette histoire et cfcf
voilà a été obligé de contre attaquer
alors pour ce qui est de la contestation
c'est vraiment important de comprendre
ce qui se passe actuellement on a eu on
a depuis des années en russie depuis
depuis l'installation du régime
poutinien des
des personnalités des ong des groupes
professionnels qui protestent qui sont
très critiques du pouvoir donc cela on
les a entendus on les a entendus dès le
début oui il ya eu des manifestations ou
les personnes courageuses sont descendus
dans la rue à protester ouvertement et
très risqué aujourd'hui dans la société
russe aujourd'hui je dirais que la
protestation s'étend un petit peu et
elle s'étend à des cercles ce ne sont
pas pour l'instant voyez les maires qui
voient leur retirer leur enfant mis en
danger sur la ligne de front parce qu'il
sait il sert dans l'armée russe qui
protestent ceux qui protestent c'est ce
qu'ils voient en fait la normalité de
l'heure de leur vie quotidienne déjà
sérieusement menacés ils ont la manière
dont ils envisagent leur avenir et
l'avenir de leur pays très clairement
menacé je vais vous donner juste un
exemple qu'on qui vient de re là une
information qui circule ce matin on a
plusieurs centaines 800 alors où je vous
parle ancien étudiant diplômé d'une
université d'élite d'état qui a toujours
été très loyal au pouvoir qui forme les
hauts diplomates les hommes d'affaires
qui est femme d'affaires qui travaillons
dans les grandes entreprises russes les
hauts fonctionnaires et bien là on a des
jeunes professionnels qui affirme
ouvertement dans une lettre ouverte qui
les met clairement en danger non ce
n'est pas la même la politique
extérieure de la russie tel qu'on nous a
enseigné tels que nous ne soutenons pas
en fait cette vision de la scène
internationale et cette vision de
l'action de la russie donc ça c'est ans
après il faut vraiment se poser la
question quelle sera la capacité
ballack auquel les prochains jours nous
donnerons des éléments et les prochaines
semaines nous donnerons des éléments
pour l'instant rien qui renverse la
table se pendre dans quelle mesure un
accolant lebedev le discours dont vous
parliez tenu par vladimir poutine de
faire porter la responsabilité aux
occidentaux sur l' escalade peut être
fragilisée par le bilan des soldats
russes qui vont être tués sur le front
ou emprisonnés ou blessés et puis est-ce
que si cette guerre devient plus brutale
encore vis-à-vis des civils est ce que
ça ça peut impacter ce discours dans
l'opinion publique
ça peut aller dans les deux sens c'est à
dire que ça dépendra justement de la
capacité des personnes actives dans la
société à percer la bulle informationnel
parce qu'après tout des cercueils qui
reviennent lorsqu'on essaie de vous
convaincre que le responsable c'est
l'otan et que vos soldats se sont
sacrifiés sur le front contre un
occident hostile et bien ma foi ça peut
au contraire conduire à une
brutalisation de la société ça peut
conduire à un soutien plus grand à la
violence donc ce n'est pas une hypothèse
impossible non plus mais il ya un
deuxième élément toutefois en plus de
voiles à de ses victimes qui vont
certainement s l'information va
certainement se diffuser dans la société
russe il y a bien évidemment l'impact de
l'isolément de la russie économique
politique d'isolement de fait de la
russie sur la scène internationale
l'impact sur ces couches de population
qui ce qui était assez protégés ils ont
ainsi bénéficié du système je pense ici
aux classes moyennes supérieures je
pense aux personnalités aisées je pense
aux hommes et femmes d'affaires est
compris
auzolle à ce qu'on appelle les
oligarques dont on fait les projets
d'avenir voyez les projets y compris
complètement personnel mercantile lié à
rodez au devenir de leur famille sont
brutalement en fait dissous et
disparaissent dans cette situation dans
cette situation catastrophique
je dirais qu'il faudrait regarder la
relation la réaction de ces putschs là à
skis à ce qui se passe ces couches qui
avait tout à fait qu'ils avaient réussi
à trouver leur place dans cet équilibre
politico-économique poutinien et qui
finalement voit la terre se disparaître
sous leurs pieds aux oligarques à
macolin lebedev dont on a entendu
corrigez moi si je me trompe fait assez
rarissime à l'expression publique de
leur a minima leurs inquiétudes voire
d'une forme de critique vis-à-vis du
kremlin est ce qu'il pourrait lâcher
d'une certaine façon vladimir poutine
est là pour le coup comme vous le disiez
l'effet serait autrement plus plus fort
difficile à dire difficile à dire pour
l'instant on a effectivement des prises
de parole publiques et je dirais que
chaque prise de parole publique par un
oligarque ou une personnalité rend la
prise de paroles suivantes moins
coûteuse le plus difficile c'est d'être
le fait d'être le premier quand on est
dans une opinion plus largement partagée
ça devient plus simple ce n'est pas pour
rien que vladimir poutine a réuni très
peu de temps après le début de
l'invasion les représentants des
entrepreneurs du milieu des
entrepreneurs donc il ne représente pas
grand monde mais disons l'idée c'était
d'envoyer un message à ses milieux
d'affaires à qui il demandait soutien je
pense qu'il n'est pas certain de leur
soutien et il n'est pas impossible qu'un
certain nombre de secousses vient
effectivement de la des oligarques bien
évidemment mais aussi de tous ceux qui
auprès du kremlin contrôle aujourd'hui
ou ont des postes de responsabilité dans
les entreprises d'état ils doivent leur
place au kremlin mais ils doivent aussi
leur prospérité y compris celles
acquises par la corruption au commerce
notamment par exemple des hydrocarbures
avec avec l'occident donc ces gens là
aussi pourrait avoir beaucoup me voilà
le calcul pour eux de coûts avantages du
soutien du kremlin pourraient ou pas une
fois de plus difficile à dire pour
l'instant basculer on comprend bien sûr
votre prudence sont pas levées ici un à
colin lebedev peut-être avec une
facilité intellectuelle en avril a dit
mir poutine enferrée dans une forme
d'obsession et d'isolement avec le
symbole bien sûr de cette table immense
au bout de laquelle il prend des
décisions est il si seul parent cela
j'entends s'il n'était plus là est ce
que d'autres que lui pour suivre et 7
cette même politique
alors là je vous avoue que je suis
incompétente pour répondre parce que les
cercles du kremlin sont relativement
opaque ce que nous savons c'est qu'il y
a différents clans qui on va là qui
gravitent autour de vladimir poutine qui
ont des influences aussi diverses le
aujourd'hui ce qui est celui qui semble
prévaloir c'est effectivement le clan de
le clan plutôt représentant les forces
de l'ordre les services spéciaux l'armée
le ministère de l'intérieur en revanche
les clans de gestionnaires eux semblent
être plus dubitatif à l'égard de ce qui
se passe après envoyé
l'admirent poutine effectivement
centralise pour l'instant les décisions
stratégiques
il nous prend pas en compte la faille
voilà il ne gère pas le pays
en micro management comme il comme il
l'a fait à un certain moment il est
plutôt isolé
on a l'impression quand même d'une
solitude qui se dégage lorsque ses plus
proches collaborateurs le ministre de la
défense avec qui il passe des vacances
d'habitude sont isolés à l'autre bout de
la table alors les ukrainiens ne marque
pas un ne manque pas de le remarquer
quand il met en fait on regarde l'image
de ce putin avec son ministre de d2
défense 10 mètres derrière lui et
l'image de des compagnons que sont
aujourd'hui le président ukrainien et
son ministre de la défense qui se
prennent en selle fille et qui ont l'air
beaucoup plus humain que effectivement
leurs homologues du kremlin voilà avec
un coup de force de poutine qui aura
galvanisés un patriotisme dont
précisément signé jusqu'ici l'existence
merci infiniment alain colin hay lebedev
d'avoir répondu à distance aux questions
de de paris direct avec plaisir sur ce
plateau j'espère un jour prochain merci
encore on se retrouve juste après la
pause pour pour la suite depart et
directe avec pauline godard
[Musique]